[Musique]
on commence les missions avec une
enquête sur le réseau de la santé parce
que madeleine vous avez découvert deux
cas de gaspillage et ça se passe dans le
domaine de la radiologie
oui deux cas où vraiment on voit qu'il
ya des fonds publics qui sont dépensés
pour payer pour des actes médicaux qui
ne sont pas nécessaires des actes
médicaux qui apporte très peu aux
patients et parfois rien du tout aux
patients madeleine vous avez découvert
des gaspillages mais vous si vous avez
vu des tensions entre le milieu de la
santé gaétan barrette
l'association des radiologistes et la
fédération des médecins spécialistes
détention je devrais même de l'hostilité
à tel point moment donné pendant une
entrevue je me suis dirai comment ces
gens là vont faire pour s'asseoir
ensemble et avoir les échanges
constructifs dont on a besoin
actuellement dans le réseau de la santé
[Musique]
vas-y 12 parties un patient doit subir
une coronarographie un examen
radiologique qui permettra de voir si
ces artères coronaires sont bloqués au
plus haut niveau
le cardiologue insère un cathéter et y
injecte produit de contraste
grâce à un appareil de rayons x les
artères apparaissent sur un écran en
temps réel une artère est bloqué à 80%
le cardiologue procède à une
angioplastie
il débloque l'artère et y installe une
endoprothèse qui l'empêchera de se
bloquer à nouveau pour l'ensemble de la
procédure le cardiologue recevra environ
750 dollars le compteur pourrait
s'arrêter là mais ce ne sera pas le cas
même si le patient est guéri et de
retour chez lui un radiologiste va
regarder les images de l'examen est
facturé 84 dollars à la régie de
l'assurance maladie un acte inutile
selon certains mais qui perdure
un acte qui permet de faire beaucoup
d'argent en peu de temps ce qui n'a pas
toujours été le cas
lorsque les coronarographies ont
commencé à être fait
c'était un examen complexe dangereux le
radiologiste j'ai lu dont a travaillé
pendant près de 40 ans à l'institut de
cardiologie de montréal et se souvient
des années 70 et 80 ou en matière de
coronarographie les radiologistes était
indispensable
les images étaient enregistrés sur film
qu'il fallait développer subséquemment
le radiologue qui connaissait les films
qui connaissait la chimie du
développement chez terra naturellement
est devenu l'interpréta table jusqu aux
années 90 le traitement par angioplastie
ne se faisait jamais en même temps que
la coronarographie les radiologistes
avait le temps de regarder les films et
d'influencer le diagnostic et le
traitement mais l'amélioration constante
de la qualité des images obtenues en
temps réel a permis aux cardiologues de
traiter les patients sur le champ
on avait vu que 22e a fort à débloquer
dès le milieu des années 90 à l'institut
de cardiologie la moitié des
coronarographies était accompagnée d'un
acte thérapeutique
et à ce moment-là d'interpréter un
examen ou le traitement avait déjà été
fait j'estimais que la valeur ajoutée de
mon acte n'était plus au rendez vous et
comme on avait beaucoup à faire et à
offrir d'autres examens qui était plus
approprié ben moi pour un jésus je pense
qu'on devrait cesser d'interpréter les
coronarographies thérapeutique vers 1997
les radiologistes de l'institut 16
d'interpréter les coronarographies
pendant lesquels les patients ont été
traités
puis vers 2012 il met fin à
l'interprétation de toutes les
coronarographies compte tenu de
l'évolution de de la maison mais ils ont
arrêté manifestement part je dirais sens
des responsabilités et en barrette a
pratiqué la radiologie pendant une
trentaine d'années il a été président de
l'association des radiologistes et la
fédération des médecins spécialistes
il connaît le milieu de la radiologie en
profondeur en décembre dernier il a
proposé d'abolir la lecture des
coronarographies par les radiologistes
dans le proposait la position ce qui
aurait évidemment été refusée et par la
fmsq et par l'association des
radiologistes du québec
après quoi et s'accrochent manifestement
assez et s'accroche à la protection d'un
certain profil de pratiques de certains
de leurs membres et évidemment à
l'élément pécuniaire qui vit avec
non c'est pas le cas en fait ce cadeau
si assez complexe et un dossier auquel
on réfléchit depuis un certain temps le
docteur vincent oliva et président de
l'association des radiologistes du
québec
c'est une question qui mérite qu'on
discute avec les milieux
qu'on fasse pas ça de façon improvisée
brouillonne système coronarien droit de
points l'interprétation des
coronarographies nous coûte 3 millions
de dollars par année
comment se fait-il qu'on continue de la
faire presque partout de nombreuses
années après que l'institut de
cardiologie et juger la pratique inutile
la situation peut être différente dans
d'autres milieux
encore une fois où il ya des
radiologistes qui font ce travail là
qu'ils font bien où le milieu apprécié
qu'ils le fassent ya aussi peu la
ceinture et les bretelles ce cas là le
moyen de se payer la ceinture et les
bretelles
c'est la question qu'on se pose en ce
moment puis c'est une bonne question
c'est quoi la valeur ajoutée n'importe
quel acte qui est fait par par un
médecin puis interprétée par un autre ça
donne un avis neutre
ça permet aussi de rattraper des fois
des erreurs
encore faut-il que l'interprétation par
le radiologiste se fasse rapidement
c'est quoi le délai utile pour les
records narrow graphie selon vous qu
elle se fasse le prêt de midi même le
lendemain même en temps d'une semaine
c'est des délais raisonnables
des délais qui sont loin d'être
respectées dans certains hôpitaux au
centre hospitalier universitaire de
sherbrooke le chu ont fait environ 3000
coronarographie par année une source
nous a fait parvenir des données portant
sur les délais de lecture de quelques
200 examens réalisés en 2014 2015 et
c'est coronarographie choisi au hasard
ont été lus par des radiologistes de 110
à 879 jours après avoir été faite des
mois des années plus tard
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on est pas
d'accord avec ce genre de pratique et ça
donne rien donné un filet de sûreté avec
un délai qui est tellement important que
le train est passé
la situation au chu ce n'est pas unique
le ministre de la santé s'en est rendu
compte après avoir proposé d'abolir
l'interprétation des coronarographies
comme ça c'était dans l'air il ya des
gens dans le réseau qui ont regardé les
examens qui était non lus depuis aix
temps et existence était jusqu'à plus de
deux ans là il ya eu un glitch
d'interprétation bri d'interprétation
c'est payant selon les données que nous
avons obtenus en une soirée de 2016
un radiologiste du chuss addict et 39
coronarographie datant de plus de 550
jours
à 84 dollars l'examen ça permet une
facturation de plus de 1000 $ l'heure
s'y trouvent
à ce stade je pense qu'on est à un
cheveu de l'immoralité
plus impressionnant encore en 3h07 il ya
quelques mois un radiologiste addict et
49 coronarographie datant de plus de 110
jours une facturation de 1300 dollars
leur temps moyen passé sur chaque
dossier ce matin là moins de quatre
minutes
j'aimerais bien les rencontrer pour
qu'il me dise comment ils font ça parce
que je ne vois pas comment on peut faire
une interprétation aussi rapide
moi mon souvenir était l effet qu une
coronographie ça nous prenait 80 et 30 à
40 minutes est apprêté encore un
aérographe i selon notre source la durée
très brève que le temps de travail des
radiologistes du chuss sur chaque examen
pourrait s'expliquer par le fait que
ceux-ci reproduisent le rapport qui a
été fait par le cardiologue
dans le cas de cinq dossiers de patients
choisi au hasard au fond stats
effectivement que les rapports sont
quasi identiques les radiologistes du
service de radiologie interventionnelle
du chuss ont répondu à nos questions par
écrit
ils admettent que la lecture aussi
tardive apporte moins aux patients et
n'est donc pas une pratique qu'il faut
faire perdurer
il explique que le délai
d'interprétation des coronarographies a
été problématique depuis les 20
dernières années due à des problèmes
d'effectif et à une apps
de priorisation par le département de
ces examens par rapport à d'autres il
ajoute que le retard est actuellement à
son plus bas au sujet des quelques
minutes passées sur chaque dossier
ils prétendent qu'il ne s'agit que du
temps de dicter des interprétations qui
aurait eu lieu à un autre moment
une façon de pratiquer que le docteur
hudon n'a jamais vu en 35 ans de
radiologie du côté de l'association des
radiologistes on nous assure que
l'abolition des interprétations de
coronarographie est à l'ordre du jour
est ce que vous sentez une ouverture de
la part de vos mains je ne dirais qu'une
une ouverture un certainement absolument
une ouverture presque 20 ans après avoir
été le premier radiologiste a proposé de
cesser la lecture des coronarographies
le dr hudon espère que le changement est
pour bientôt
c'est une question de pertinence de
continuer à faire des examens qui sont
non pertinent baisse c'est dommage parce
qu'il ya où il ya autre chose à faire il
ya tellement d'autres choses à faire
[Musique]
après la pause la prescription
d'échographie inutile explose depuis que
la procédure est gratuite pour les
patients en clinique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est de retour enquête et madeleine
pour bien comprendre le prochain segment
on a besoin de votre aide
les médecins travaillent pas seulement
en hôpital non il ya trois endroits où
les médecins peuvent travailler que les
hôpitaux où tout ce que les médecins
font et remboursés par la régie de
l'assurance maladie du québec la ram qu
à ses systèmes publics
à côté de ça il ya les cliniques privées
où ce sont des médecins qui sont
propriétaires des lieux mais où tout ce
qu'ils font est aussi remboursés par la
ramq comme à l'hôpital comme une
extension du système public et à l'autre
bout du spectre violent et cliniquement
j'appelle privé privé ce sont des
médecins qui sont propriétaires et où
tout ce qu'ils font ils le facturent aux
patients parce qu'ils sont désengagés de
la régie de l'assurance maladie est là
dans le coq vous avez une présenté dans
un instant on parle vraiment décliné que
les médecins sont propriétaires mais où
tous les gestes sont remboursés par la
ramq eu c'est surtout les gestes sauf
trois l'échographie l'irm la résonance
magnétique et le scan
historiquement ces trois actes et là
quand les médecins les faisait à
l'hôpital
ils étaient remboursés par la ramq eu
mais quand il les faisait dans leur
clean et ils pouvaient facturer les
patients est facturé des montants
considérables mais comme on le sait les
listes d'attentes sont longues alors
pour y échapper les patients évidemment
se tourner vers les cliniques privées
oui mais ça c est en train de se
terminer le ministre guéant barrette a
décidé de changer ça et on a découvert
que ça se passe super bien
keira des plongeons échographie
pelvienne
une échographie de quoi échographie
comme louis vendredi 15 septembre 2010
est à la clinique de radiologie léger et
associé de montréal c'est la journée du
mois où l'on donne les rendez vous pour
les échographies du mois suivant
vous découvrirez fait pelvienne on
distingue téléphonie en ligne le matin
aux alentours de 2 heures un petit peu
plus peut-être il y en a peu plus grande
et vous le pot tout le monde octobre
pour tout le monde acteurs savons le 2
octobre
qu'est ce qui arrive quand il ya plus de
rendez vous malheureusement il faut
qu'ils attendent romo qui suit mais
rendue au mois d'octobre donc votre
numéro d'assurance maladie avant ces
patients ac les pieds on était capable
d'offrir un rendez-vous dans les cinq à
dix jours ouvrables en moyenne grandi
voulons jours avant c'était avant que
des échographies deviennent gratuites
dans les cliniques de radiologie privée
à la suite d'un décret du ministre
guettant barrette en décembre 2016
un coup de force qui a provoqué la
colère des radiologistes on n'a pas eu
une seule rencontre de planification on
nous est arrivé avec une solution
imposée alors qu'on l'avait dit vous
offrir un bar ouvert
politiquement c'est peut être payant dit
regardez c'est gratuit mais à mon sens
on sait pas le temps de jouer au père
noël parce que les ressources sont
limitées
depuis que les patients n'ont plus à
payer il semble que les médecins
prescrivent beaucoup plus d'échographie
jouait beaucoup plus examen pour toutes
sortes de petites bosses sur la peau
puis ganglions des pontes ça des fois
bon c'est une autre question un peu de
patience est là depuis x années il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas matière à investiguer
36,6
l'association des radiologistes vient de
recevoir les résultats d'un sondage
qu'il a commandé et qu'ils démontrent
que la gratuité des examens en clinique
arrive en effet pervers
ça n'a pas réussi à désengorger la tente
qu'ils avaient dans le milieu
hospitalier
il ya eu un allongement très
significatif de la tente dans les
cabinets privés qui fonctionnait bien
avant et si on prend ça au global avant
les réformes environ 50% des patients
avaient accès aux services échographique
en deux semaines alors qu'actuellement
s'acheter à moins de 20%
le docteur vincent oliva est
particulièrement préoccupée par
l'allongement des délais pour
l'obtention d'une échographie mammaire
s'est passé deux ans dans une semaine à
jusqu'à 5 à 11 semaines d'attentes
alors que les cliniques peine encore à
s'organiser pour répondre à la demande
une nouvelle surprise les attend si la
fin du monde est en fait d'ici le
printemps 2010 suit la tendance mais tri
et la résonance magnétique bonne couleur
palmade
le ministre veut faire avec le scanner
l'irm la même chose qu'avec
l'échographie vous êtes chanceuse parce
qu'il nous en a peu parlé un outil on
est les premiers concernés
ce n'est visiblement pas l'harmonie
entre le ministre l'association des
radiologistes et la fédération des
médecins spécialistes le filet trois
dernières années on a beaucoup de
difficulté à collaborer avec le
gouvernement
l'atmosphère n'est pas aussi conviviale
que le toujours été auparavant à cause
la personnalité du ministre il s'est
donné tous les pouvoirs dont il contrôle
tout à quelques reprises pendant les
entrevues
nous avons vraiment eu l'impression d'un
dialogue de sourds
pourquoi vous avez réassurer les
échographies uniquement car ce sont des
radiologistes qu'il est fort pourquoi
pas les autres médecins c'est leur choix
poser leurs questions pourquoi les
radiologistes seulement je vous répète
mon endroit le ministre mission dans le
règlement point final
donc ce n'est pas le choix de la fmsq du
tout de confier ce que ce soit que les
radiologistes qui soit en bourse est
absolument pas ses ministres les
règlements ce pour moi il a
non c'est sur les ondes d'une radio très
populaire à montréal
c'est comme ça qu'on l'a appris selon
vincent oliva la réforme du ministre
barrettes sur les échographies aurait pu
se faire sans impact négatif sur les
patients si au lieu d'être imposée elle
avait été planifié en collaboration avec
les radiologistes et l'annoncent de la
réforme sur l'irm et le scan fait
craindre le pire
l'association des radiologistes prétend
qu'elle pourrait avoir un impact
marginal sur l'accessibilité tout en
coûtant des dizaines de millions de plus
à l'état
mais alors ça ici l'achat maintenant
regardez là un réseau logue qui se borne
pour maintenir le côté privé de la
radiologie 9,9 fois sur dix c'est pour
un intérêt pécuniaire
pourquoi parce que le même examen
rapporte dans les poches des réseaux
donnent beaucoup plus que dans public
sera long c'est une vérité absolue
absolue c'est une vérité de gaëtan
barrette mais dans le fond c'est un
écran de fumée
il est vrai que les radiologistes
propriétaires de cliniques font moins de
profits depuis que les échographies sont
couvertes par la ramq eu et ce sera la
même chose avec l'irm et le scan
mais serra du registre sont une minorité
la majorité travaillent dans les
hôpitaux
et c'est là qu'il souhaite que des fonds
supplémentaires soit investi il ya déjà
des tdm et des irm un établissement qui
servent accroché le cerveau parce qu'ils
sont dans une salle qui n'est pas
utilisé parce qu'on n'a pas les
techniciennes parce qu'on n'a pas les
ressources parce qu'on a pas les budgets
d'opération comme en milieu hospitalier
en quémande auprès de la direction du
personnel puis on se bat on veut ouvrir
le nouveau chum et puis on se bagarre
pour avoir du personnel peau pour
s'assurer que tout ce bel équipement à
leveaux fonctionné puis dormira pas le
soir puis les week-ends
le québec est l'une des provinces qui
utilisent le moins ces appareils irm
publics les chiffres que nous avons
obtenus sont éloquents en colombie
britannique
un appareil fait en moyenne 10 mai
l'examen par année en ontario c'est 5000
en alberta 6200 et au québec
4600 lieu d appareil de résonance
magnétique
it is khan qui fonctionne 24 heures sur
24 dans d'autres provinces csp au québec
on coupe dans certains hôpitaux où les
délais d'attentes sont très lents on ne
fait que 3600 ou 2500 examen par annick
par appareil alors que dans d'autres
hôpitaux
on en fait plus de 9000 pourquoi on
optimise pas c'est exactement ce que
j'ai annoncé avant noël
en 2006 un investissement immédiat de
4,5 millions de dollars et j'ai donné la
consigne à tous les établissements du
québec sans exception là où une liste
d'attendre de faire fonctionner les
scanne les résonances cinq heures par
jour sept jours sur sept
le jour où ce sport pleinement en
fonction dans nos veines moyenne ils
voient tout à fait comparable à d'autres
en fait les quatre millions et demi
supplémentaires injectés par le ministre
devrait permettre de réaliser environ
600 examens supplémentaires par appareil
ce qui nous placera encore loin derrière
les autres provinces
à moins d'investissement beaucoup plus
généreux les cliniques privées devront
continuer de palier à l'incapacité des
hôpitaux de répondre à la demande n'est
pas un secret que le ministre aimerait
que la médecine
une partie de la médecine sans nadal
privé alors je comprends que peut-être
que c'est moins coûteux d'opérer des
examens dans le système privé dans le
système public
sauf que je pense que le réseau public
c'est une force de notre système de
santé
le ministre espère peut être faire des
économies en transférant une partie des
examens dans les cliniques privées où
ceux ci pourrait coûter moins cher qu'à
l'hôpital
de nombreux radiologiste de leur côté
espèrent sans doute pouvoir continuer de
facturer aux patients les scanner les
irm qu'ils font dans leur clinique parce
que ceux-ci leur rapporte plus qu'à
l'hôpital
la négociation ne sera pas facile